alors il ya eu des scènes aussi censuré
par la f1 notamment il ya une scène on a
réussi à se procurer dans laquelle
hélène et drogué à son insu avec un
space cake un gâteau au cannabis et
ouais ouais non un moment s est parti en
4 4 2 alors mellouli non mais c'est vrai
et élèves
moi je me rappelle de saint céré
qu'hélène elles avaient été droguées par
les producteurs de musique si je connais
tous un jour lui permet de bien voir
je ne débarque pas et je m'en rappelle
nicolas la chercher de massage ma faveur
et ouais exactement thomas brasch aussi
détesté lui le pot sur les cuisses et
dans les mystères
à oui elle va très bien voilà on regarde
et c'est tout ce que je gâte on peut
faire des miracles si vous êtes une
bande de filles que j'ai eu quand cesc
est dedans
[Rires]
c'est pas mal du tout et ça me surprend
de la part de nicolas ducron petit
faussement sérieuse ne t'inquiète pas
c'est bon tu veux coucher avec elle ce
soir oui ou pas bien sûr ça c'était mais
même cette phrase si tu savais le nombre
de filles que j'ai eue grâce à ce qu'il
ya dedans
ouais mais bon oui mais attention cette
affection ouais c'est ça aussi dans sa
là tu vas dire ouais elle avait fait
scandale et plaqué or le monde a vu un
problème c'est que c'était des émissions
dans le cadre de la famille jeunesse
ouais donc on pouvait montrer de la
drogue mais il fallait que ce soit
résolu à la fin de l'épisode accord
alors comme c'était pure plusieurs
épisodes ils n'ont pas pu l'utiliser
pour cette raison parce que l'émission
n'était pas puni à la fin de l'épisode
d'accord tu vois alors après loi à
l'époque
non mais il ya eu plein de trucs là il
ya eu il ya eu des petits problèmes dans
il ya eu des extraits censure est donc
dans hélène et les garçons avec le space
cake
il ya eu un autre épisode qui avait été
censuré à cause de violences aussi on y
découvre les garçons qui veulent venger
leurs amis taxi victime de tentative de
viol du trapel de ça ou pas je m'emballe
pas de ça je le spectacle en somme pas
de ça alors ça y est ça et aussi un
autre pack eric zemmour en quatre ans en
il est tombé en est déjà attaqué hélène
et les garçons accusant la syrie
expliquant que les hommes sont devenus
des chapeaux des femmes à cause des j'ai
lu ça oui cette histoire drôle ah ouais
c'est vrai il était trop gentil et il ya
eu donc cette fameuse aussi relations
entre anet et monsieur girard dans les
mystères de l'amour qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre sachons en appelle
aussi c'est un truc de fou parce qu'il
était tellement attaché aux personnages
les gens c'est vrai que ça les a sali la
chaufferie mairie toute une histoire il
s'est créé comme quai berteaux
l'australie a noté partie notions en
australie il était malade elle l'a
soignée puis voilà alors après il ya eu
aussi les filles d'à côté
[Musique]
ajoutez y avait notamment gérard yvé
s'inquiéter l'alaska la série puis les
trois filles claire fanny et magali
avait marqué et daniel aussi
agréablement là exactement et je vous
propose de regarder le générique on va
recevoir ensuite patricia et lichens et
stéphanie dans la suite de la série
regarde
[Musique]
eh oui
des filles d'à côté merci la cre avec no
mercy par laeticia m'a dit vous êtes
régalés à faire les fidèles j'ai adoré
c'était génial
ah non c'était les vacances